la bière sans alcool connaît du succès
non seulement chez nous mais ailleurs
dans le monde
cette catégorie de bière va continuer
d'ailleurs de progresser selon les
prévisions en 2021
la taille de ce marché au québec s'élève
à plus de 21 millions de dollars avec
nous ce soir sébastien paradis pdg les
brasseurs du nord qui est vraiment une
microbrasserie pionnière au québec bien
connu pour sa marque boréale bonsoir
monsieur paradis
bonsoir parlons d'abord de l'ensemble de
l'industrie de la microbrasserie est-ce
que la pandémie a eu du bon pour votre
industrie
elle a défini définitivement eu du bon
n'est pas que du bon je pense que ce qui
était bien de cette pandémie c'est qu'on
a eu une conscientisation du
consommateur sur l'achat local et
d'encourager c'est l'industrie
québécoise d'investir dans sa communauté
donc pour nous ce ça a été ça a été très
positif et on a vu une augmentation là
en général des parts de marché de la
micro brasserie en épicerie ce qui est
moins positif c'est qu'on sauve tous des
partenariats qu'on a avec les bars les
restaurants les événements puis tous les
regroupements qui commençait n'existe
presque plus depuis 10 mois quelle part
de vos revenus viennent des bars et des
restaurants
brassant du nord pour nous si on peut
parler d'environ le 20 % de nos revenus
qui viennent qui viennent de cette
industrie là mais pour l'industrie de la
microbrasserie c'est ça fluctue
département il ya des microbrasseries
qui qui en fait son temps un bar et un
restaurant il ya beaucoup aux brasseries
qui sont un pub dont on consomme
beaucoup plus alors que d'autres qu'on
semble sur l'aventin d'épicerie donc
c'est pas tout le monde qui vis de la
même façon mais pour nous lambert aurait
pour ça on a été une cro brasse qui
étaient fondés sur de très bonnes
relations le avec les bars et les
restaurants donc on trouve ça très très
difficile en ce moment c'est pour ce
segment la démarche est ce que les
marges sont meilleures dans les bars et
restaurants pour les microbrasseries
habituellement oui je suis au niveau de
dieu
de l'emballage on parle d'en bas restera
c'est souvent du fus donc le fus a en
général va nous donner de meilleures
marges que la bouteille ou de la canette
avec les tic ethic tout ce que ça
représente le pour la le conditionnement
de ces produits là donc oui en plus
d'être une un pourcentage important de
notre business pc 1% sur un segment
marche ikeda plus haute marche pour les
ventes dans l'épicerie est ce que la
dernière année a été très bonne ce qu'on
a même augmenté les ventes en épicerie
oui je ne peux pas encore pour
l'industrie au complet mais j'aurais
tendance à dire que oui et chez nous oui
puis à on pense que c'est
c'est en partie comme le dit au début à
cette conscientisation là des gens
d'acheter local d'encourager leurs
industries locales
un clip a très tôt fait que légères ont
eu besoin de prendre une bière aussi une
fois soir et ce1 pecci mai mais là les
gens auraient besoin effectivement puis
on a même noté une augmentation de la
consommation d'alcool au cours de la
dernière année
mais là vous vous lancez vous vous
tournez notamment vers les bières sans
alcool dites nous pourquoi une tendance
qu'on vous l'avez vous l'avais dit la
nôtre et just un marché qui continue à
croître au canada aux états-unis en
europe et il ya plusieurs hypothèses
avec ça mais je pense qu'une chi chi chi
qu'on sait c'est qu'une plus grande les
légions mon père attention à leur bien
être leur santé est assez volatile
souvent on se lance là dopent les gens
il ya tant de gens qui boivent pas
d'alcool ainsi pas nécessairement les
gens qui boivent pas d'alcool mais c'est
les gens qui veulent modérer leur
consommation d'alcool alors ce qu'on
voit souvent qui on l'a vu peut-être ça
a été encore plus mis de l'avant la lors
de cette pandémie la tête qu'on sort -
puis on se met à boire on se rend compte
qu'on boit de l'alcool cinq jours six
jours seulement
donc il ya des gens qui vont se dire
pour ma santé peut-être que je devrais
aussi diminué à 2 à 3 jours semaine
c'est là que le produit devient
intéressante pour ces autres jours où on
veut diminuer notre consommation mais de
quand même avoir un produit qui était
intéressant consommer à boire et on a
travaillé là pendant longtemps développé
chemin
dhuicq y est on a tous eu d'aidé à un
moment ou un autre des expériences qui
sont plus ou moins satisfaisants de
produits sans alcool qui qui réussissent
pas vraiment à égaler la version avec
alcool puis on pense qu'après à près de
80 recettes qu'on a fait on a réussi à
lever un produit qui qui va vraiment
agréable à boire aux pieds c'est ce
qu'on espère qu'on va offrir aux
consoles et donc ça représente tout ça
représentera quelle part de l'ensemble
de vos ventes par rapport aux bières
avec alcool pour nous ça va être lancée
en ce moment donc cette gamme hors
sentiers là qu'on appelle va représenter
leur bâti 5% pour pour la première année
c'est évident mais encore une fois pour
nous c'est c'la potentiel de croissance
ici au québec 1 mais aussi à l'étranger
de d'un tel produit donc on est très
enthousiaste vous et qui contient déjà
de vos bières à l'étranger ça fait
trente deux ans nous qu'on était qu'on
initie au québec et ça fait seulement
deux heures qu'on a commencé
l'exportation hors québec états unis
plusieurs de ses usines aux etats-unis
ontario et même un peu à l'europe il ya
plusieurs de ces initiatives le
stratégique qui était peut-être sur un
horizon de cinq à dix ans qui ont été
mis de l'avant leur encore une fois des
conséquences de la pandémie où l'on
parle un segment important du match on
en parle et on t'aurait par les
restaurants dont pour nous ça a été tout
d'un coup un électrochoc de dire on va
se concentrer sur d'autres avenues de
notre développement stratégique et
l'exportation les ventes au québec en
est un pour nous qui est content qu'on a
mis de l'avant peut-être plus rapidement
et on se rend compte que ce marché qui
peut être très intéressant les très
intéressant les états unis l'ontario est
un marché assez protectionnistes ont à
travers la s6 bio c'est plus difficile
mais lui rappelé on voit qu'il ya une
grande appréciation aussi pour la la
culture québécoise et nous boréale avec
cette source
on voit que ça résonne bien avec le
consommateur français aussi et vous
allez vendre dans quelques secondes
aussi votre votre bière sans alcool à
l'étranger oui on veut essayer aussi
tout à fait c'est on a dit c'est sa
croissance lov cette conscientisation du
consommateur voulant peut-être modérer
un peu sa consommation d'alcool est s
bois l'international donc pourquoi pas
on est en train de travailler sur
l'emballage pour pour les autres marchés
l'asseyait la part découvrir
bonne chance et batipart a dit merci
beaucoup ça me fait grand plaisir merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit